بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد كين ان
الوجيز في كتاب الطهاره
في باب مستحبات الوضوء
صلى الله عليه وسلم
‏are
before
of if you imagine
let say a car
a car has an engine a transmission it
has tir
‏steingel
things to not car things
you have
to car
and addition are the car stand outils
per
this is what you areally do when
[Silence]
‏handit leher seats having you very
all the scratches all the blishes
الله سبحانه وتعالى
يقول المؤلف من مستحبات
الوضوء الدعاء الدعاء بعد الوضوء لقوله
صلى الله عليه وسلم ما منكم من احد يتوضا
فيسبغ الوضوء يسبغ يعني يكمل و
يعمم الوضوء ويتقن الوضوء ثم يقول اشهد ان
لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له واشهد ان
محمدا عبده ورسوله
الا فتحت له ابواب الجنه الثمانيه يدخل من
ايها شاء زاد الترمذي
اللهم اجعلني من التوابين واجعلني من
المتطهرين
ان الله يحب التوابين ويحب
فالانسان يتطهر
ويقول هذه وهذه الروايه عند الامام مسلم
في صحيحه وعند الترمذي في جامعه باسناد
صحيح soش
دعاء
الوضو
صلى الله عليه
اشهد ان اله الا الله
وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
‏parad
[Silence]
المتطهرين
وضو اشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك
له واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله اللهم
اجعلني من التوابين واجعلني من المتطهرين
دعا
وضو
anyاء
[Silence]
‏is noticated
is what the
schar would say hypocr meaning it is not
trustwthy so there are no authentic
narrations regarding making and
وضوء بعض الاخوه العرب ممكن يسمع بعض
الادعيه يدعى بها الداعي وقت وضوئه
اذا
وضا وجهه قال اللهم بيض وجهي يوم تبيض
الوجوه وتسود وجوه واذا وضا
يمينه قال اللهم اتني
يميني واذا وضا شماله قال اللهم لا
تعطيني او لا
تؤتني كتابي بشمالي واذا مسح راسه قال
واذا غسل قدمه قال هذه الروايات كلها
موضوعه مكذوبه على رسول الله واكثرها
ماخوذه من الشيعه من الرافضه
يقول عن ابي سعيد ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قال من توضا فقال
سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك اشهد ان لا اله الا
انت استغفرك واتوب اليك كتب في رق
الرق
الصحيفه البيضاء يقال له رق في رق منشور
في في القران في الايه الرق هو الصحيفه
يقول كتب في رق ثم طبع بطابع فلا يكسر الى
يوم القيامه والحديث عند الحاكم في
مستدركه والطيسي
او الطبراني في في الاوسط ولم يصح في
الدعاء اثناء الوضوء شيء
زاد المؤلف
الحاكم الطيالسي
الطبراني
في معجمه الاوسط
ابي سعيد الخد صلى الله عليه وسلم
وضو
سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك
الله
اشهد ان لا اله الا انت
استغفرك واتوب اليك
صلى الله عليه وسلم
un
‏broken until
the
authentically
making
while
so have here
person
make before he say بسم if he say any
ولم
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
واشهد ان محمدا عبده ورسوله
هي ادم اجعلني من التوابين واجعلني من
المتطهرين
ان هي اد سبحانك اللهم وبحمدك
اشهد ان لا اله الا انت استغفرك واتوب
اليك
[Silence]
said
‏are
people make up
and
اله الا الله وحده لا شريك له
صلى الله عليه
‏andis
a perfect of something that makes your
more acceptable more appealing to
acceptance
however that's not in every instance
[Silence]
‏would make
place
make
prop
‏makeعا you canise your hand also making
with the finger
this is another qu of this is another
that makes moreing however not any all
cases is only inances
the صلى الله عليه وسلمعا
سباحه
دعاء عند الاستسقاء
الاستقاء
دعاء خطبه
[Silence]
تشهد
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
andinkle
قبله
would makeعا some would
notight
and would
صلاه
سجودعاء
ركوع
تسبيح
تشهد
صلى الله عليه وسلم
تشهد الاراميعا
صلاه
wasing
would
make
these areing
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى بمنه وكرمه وجوده
وعطائه ورحمته ان يعلمنا من ديننا ما
جهلنا وان يذكرنا من كتابه ما نسينا وان
يجعل قلوبنا وافئدتنا اوعيه لكتابه ووحيه
وان يفقهنا في ديننا وان يجعل مصيبتنا فيه
والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم على نبينا